oh yeah absolutely I understand the
universe as a whole I know it's funny
there some people will say to me think
theory what a strange concept and then I
sometimes will say well of course thing
theory is a kind of a joke and people
will say oh yes because it's a play on
string theory and that's actually not
the joke but I mean but it's but it's
interesting that that a bunch of people
do and I'm sure that with enough effort
I could actually make that joke really
work for for a few people and for myself
the joke as I understand it is much more
oh surely things are precisely not what
is theory you know like oh gee you know
one races to the concrete in order to
avoid theory so now you know now we have
to actually have thing theory along with
all these other theories that for me is
more of the joke